hi so uh Welcome to our talk I'm Eyal
from IBM research and I'm here with
Giannis for also from IBM research today
we will present the open source no code
labels system and explain how you can
use it to quickly create your own text
classifiers
to motivate our work I'll start with a
true story IBM lawyers came to us with a
problem they had a collection of very
long contracts and needed to identify
Clauses within those contracts that
signify a risk
manually searching and reading hundreds
of long legal documents was obviously
extremely inefficient and expensive thus
they came to us asking if we could help
them leverage machine learning to train
a text classifier to create a model that
would automatically classify the
contracts for them as the Clauses as
risky or not risky
at this point the obvious answer
for us as machine learning expert was to
work with them and help them train a
model for their particular use case
however having been there before we knew
that this would not scale
whenever the need of the lawyers changes
for instance they need to identify a new
type of risk they would come to us back
to us and would have to repeat the whole
process all over again thus we started
asking ourselves instead of creating a
one-off model for them could we build a
general labeling and model building
system that would allow lawyers to build
a text classifier themselves without our
help so welcome to labels tools an
interactive no Code system that enables
domain experts such as our lawyers to
quickly create their own text
classifiers
taking a step back the general problem
we are trying to solve looks like this
domain experts have a large collection
of documents whose texts they need to
classify through a machine learning
model
since they may not know machine learning
they typically reach out to machine
learning experts and this is where a
week or even months long process of
unsynchronous model building begins
the process typically consists of two
alternating stage in the first stage the
domain expert painstakingly annotate a
lot of documents what should they label
when do they stop in reality the
decision is often arbitrary as they
receive limited guidance by the machine
learning experts
in the second stage
the domain expert is out of the picture
and machine learning expert then take
the labeled data which is static at that
point and try to train a model in this
process they find labeling consistencies
insufficient examples for some
categories and redundant examples for
others
and which in hindsight was a waste of
leveling time based on their Insight
they go back and ask the domain expert
for additional labeling
with limited interaction between those
rounds of labeling and model training
weeks and month can pass before a domain
expert can finally use their machine
learning model
this make model labeling expensive and
out of the reach from many domain
experts it is a real barrier for many to
do supervised machine learning we hear
it from
customers that they don't start the
machine learning because of the labeling
barrier
to avoid these issues we present level
sleuth a labeling and model building
system that makes domain expert the main
drivers of the model building process
and allow them to autonomously create
their own text classifiers
without requiring the help of machine
learning expert
labels serves in some way as the
personal machine learning expert
assistant
to those domain expert continuously
assisting and guiding domain experts
through the combined labeling and model
training process
in short labus loose is an open source
no Code system that allows domain
experts to quickly build text classifier
for their use cases no AI is knowledge
is required to accomplish that labels
list combines the following features
first an intuitive graphical user
interface allowing domain expert to
quickly start labeling their data with
no need for complex configuration or
understanding of technical jargon
usually with very minimal training to
start using the system
sorry
why the domain expert is labeling the
data labels automatically trains an
appropriate machine learning in the
background and as the user provides
additional labels labels automatically
trains improved versions of the same
model
all this happens
and transparently and to the user
complex decisions such as the type of
the model to train when new training
should be invoked and other things are
automatically made by the system
to avoid wasted and wasted labeling
effort labels does not let domain
experts simply label it random instead
it employs a variety of machine learning
and NLP techniques to guide them into
what label next and how to make most of
their limited and often expensive time
finally
why label sloth is easy to use out of
the box for domain expert it is also it
also allows for extensive customization
for more advanced user that may want to
use the system for their own use cases
or to support domain expert I imagine
most of the audience here is a part of
this set of advanced users the
combination of these features leads to a
system tailored specifically to
non-technical domain experts
okay so to better demonstrate the ease
of use of the system let us quickly demo
how a domain expert can use labels to
create their own text classifier
for this demo please meet Vicky Vicky is
a Wikipedia editor with deep knowledge
about animals to improve animal Pages
she wants to to she wants to find
sentences that describe the habitat of
animals such as the one that you can see
on the screen
our goal is to review and correct this
information if needed and also to find
pages that currently misses miss the
habitat information Vicky is not keen to
manually read every single animal page
on Wikipedia instead she will use labels
to create a classifier that identifies
habitat sentences automatically for her
okay so she start with uploading her
data of a pre-processed document it's a
simple CSV file with two columns text
and possibly document ID and then if you
create a workspace which is like a
project that can bundle several
categories of our classifiers together
now you can see the main screen of
labels loose in the middle you can see a
one of the pages of Wikipedia then she
starts defining the Habit habitat as the
category of interest and start labeling
elements for that category she can skim
through documents a label the sentences
one by one as you can see now but this
won't be very productive as a habitat
sentences are quite real to quickly find
positive examples she uses the search
functionality to find sentences that
contains contain the word habitat note
that not all of them are positive
examples she goes through a few search
results that quickly labels them as
positive or negative
when needed she clicks on a sentence to
see it within its document and make a
decision based on its context
she continued by searching additional
terms such as lives in is endemic too to
find more examples and label them
while she is labeling labels loose
collects her labels and decides when
it's time to start training a first
version of the classifier this is done
automatically in the background without
interfering with the labeling process
when a first version as you can see now
of the classifier is ready labels
notifies wiki wiki through a confetti
animation sviki provides more example
labels automatically trains new improved
version of the classifiers
once label sleuth has trained the first
version of the classifier Viki start to
receive additional labeling assistance
and this is the new part first of all
she can see a list of sentences that the
system suggests three labels and these
are the sentences that labels loose
things would be most valuable to improve
the classifier Vicky goes ahead that
label the suggested elements
since labor tools has already built the
first of all model and Wiki can also
check its predictions meaning the
sentence says it identifies as positive
examples for instance while checking
this page about a African elephant she
can easily impact the small number of
sentences identified by the classifier
these are those sentences with framed
with the bullish dotted line
she sees that the first prediction is
wrong corrects it and the next two are
correct by validating those predictions
or correcting them as needed Wiki helps
the classifier corrects its mistakes and
improve in the in the next iteration
while labeling it is natural to
introduce mistakes while these are often
unavoidable avoidable it is good to
identify them early on to avoid
introducing noise into the classifier
and to this end labels loose surfaces
the sentences whose labels are
suspicious and allow Wiki to inspect and
if needed correct them
we can Vicky can also initiate an
evaluation test to get a better
estimation of the classifier Precision
this is very helpful to determine when
it's time to stop labeling
okay when Wiki says that the
classifier's predictions are getting
better and its Precision evaluation is
good she can stop labeling and start
using the classifier she can use the
classifier in three different ways the
first that you see here is the simplest
way to upload new documents and then the
classifier's prediction through label
sleuth
UI as usual
alternatively she can download the
classifier itself and hand it over to a
developer to integrate it into a
downstream application
or she can even download the row labels
and use them herself or with someone
else and help to train another model
outside label sloof thus treating labor
Susan as an extremely efficient labeling
tool
to summarize people who use label sleuth
have reported that it is that it's have
that it has saved them a lot of time
that it is easy to use fun and even a
bit addictive
and now and with that I'll now pass you
to my friend Dianes for an in-depth
analysis of labor source features
I'll stop sharing my screen Janice and
you can do it
hello everyone can you can you see my
screen
ah no we just can hear you
let me try again
and does it work now
not yet
okay if not Al do you mind sharing and
yeah I will continue sharing my screen
and this one
two set
Giannis there you see the screen not yet
it is here
let's try something
about now
Dennis
Steve I think it's because I'm backstage
is it possible
Steve the mother
foreign
I'm sorry I see
that there that I share my screen
I can stop sharing it but you don't see
it
yes I don't
and
so we need
we need your help here Steve
yes
yeah sorry about that uh so I'm doing
the same as before but now my screen is
just I can see it but not uh
yeah yeah honestly we tried uh sharing
your screen
uh yes
I'll I'll just uh
I'll just be Bruton remove both of you
from the stream and then re-adge you
okay sounds good thank you
all right I can see your screen your uh
slides now labels loose I don't see you
I don't see your face though
I think his numbers oh there you go
thanks a lot okay then I can go ahead
and give you good Al button
that I can go ahead with the
presentation
right thanks
now that we have seen the efficient
model building experience that labels
Luth allows let's see what are the
features that enable this experience
having seen label flutes intuitive UI we
will next we
focus on the three other features
integrated model training functionality
label link assistance and
customizability and we will explain them
one by one
okay
to make the model building experience
accessible to non-technical domain
experts label sleuth offers integrated
model training functionality
while the domain experts are labeling
labels with automatically to end the
classifier in the background without
requiring any intervention by the user
in order to accomplish this labels lose
automatically makes a lot of decisions
that are related to model training in
the background these are decisions such
as what is the type of model machine
learning model that should be trained
should be a support Vector machine
should it be a bird model Etc
the second decision is how to address a
potential data set skill when domain
experts label they may for instance
provide a lot of positive examples but
they may barely provide any negative
examples this may lead to a very severe
skew in the label data that the system
has to deal with and to resolve before
it can use this data for training
and third
the system has also to decide when it
should start training the model and how
often it should retain the model as the
label the labeler provides more and more
label data
traditionally these are decisions that
would have been made by a technical
person that builds the model but in the
case of label sleuth these are automated
to the use of integrated policies that
take care of each of these aspects
the domain expert does not need to chime
in and does not even need to be aware of
them
that being said as we will see later
libert also offers Advanced users the
ability to customize and tweak these
integrated policies to their liking if
they prefer
in addition to abstracting the machine
learning process another way in which
label sleuth makes the process
accessible to non-technical users is by
offering continuous labeling assistance
labeling is pretty expensive and leaving
domain experts label in an unguided
fashion could lead very easily to wasted
effort in order to avoid that labels
lose
guides domain experts to the entire
labeling process in particular it helps
domain experts understand what they
should be labeling
how they should be labeling it and when
they can stop labeling and can start
using their classifier
first of all
it guides them in what to label
intuitively not all labels have the same
value for instance labeling a lot of
very similar elements is arguably not as
useful as labeling a more diverse set of
elements
this is why labels lose
tries to focus the labeling effort on
the examples that are more viable for
the model to improve this is done
through the use of an active learning
technique that produces a ranked list of
examples that are more beneficial to be
labeled in order to be to lead to
improvements of the model
label soothing operates multiple Active
Learning technique but the default
policy is based on uncertainty based
sampling
in a nutshell uncertainty based sampling
picks the elements that the model is
most uncertain about so the elements
that the model cannot
confidently tell whether the positive or
negative in technical terms this could
be the elements that are close to the
decision boundary between the positive
and the negative classes
in addition to suggesting to the user
what to label it also offers some
guidance on how the domain experts
should be labeling things
it is not uncommon that during the
labeling process labeling consistencies
are introduced for instance the domain
expert May label something as positive
then take a coffee break and then come
back and label a very similar element as
negative
what is important is to identify this
inconsistencies early on and to resolve
them to avoid into it using noise into
the underlying classifier
to do this label sleuth offers two ways
of identifying and surfacing labeling
errors the first one is the
identification of suspicious labels to
do that it takes the predictions of the
currently to end classifier and Compares
them to the labels that the user has
provided and it finds elements where the
classifier disagrees with the human
provided label and these are intuitively
elements that are suspicious it means
that this could potentially be labeled
to run by the user
um please note that there is much more
to it but in for the purposes of this
talk we should convey the intuition
in addition to identifying suspicious
labels the system also identifies what
we call contradicting pairs of elements
these are elements that are very similar
to each other semantically
but they have been labeled by the user
in different ways so one of them has
building labeled positive and the other
has been labeled negatively and
imperatively this again pairs of
examples where a labeling error may have
occurred so it the domain expert could
inspect them and collect one of the
labels if needed
last but not least the system also
provides information on when the domain
experts should stop labeling while using
the system to label data can be
enjoyable remember that this is not the
end goal so the end goal is to create a
good classifier thus the system is
trying to help the domain expert
understand when the classifier is good
enough so that they can stop labeling
and start using it to this Center
provides the domain expert with a way to
evaluate the model
at any point in time the domain exploit
can invoke a Precision evaluation at
that point the system will Auto generate
a sample of elements for the domain
expert label and after they have been
labeled it will estimate and present to
the user the Precision of the current
classifier
and when the user thinks that the
performance of the model is high enough
they can stop the labeling process and
start using the model
okay
let us now talk about the
customizability of the system so far we
have talked about features that are
related to domain experts non-technical
users which are also the primary target
users of the system
however Sal mentioned there is also a
second set of users that we found can
benefit from the system these are more
technical users that may want to use the
system either for it themselves or while
supporting domain experts
to facilitate the use of the system by
these small Advanced users a label truth
is built on a highly customizable
architecture most of the features that
we have presented above can be
customized so among others the type of
model to be trained the way to deal with
the data set skew the Criterion to
decide whether to invoke training or not
the active learning algorithm Etc
and in order to allow customization
label through softwares a tier two-tier
customization architecture
common customizations can be easily done
by customizing the configuration file
for instance let's say that we want to
forego the default model that we
streamed by the system and want to pick
a different one label sleuth comes
pre-implemented with different types of
machine learning models including knife
base support Vector machine code
and what we can do is select one of them
by editing the configuration file MP5
favorite model is not there then we can
easily extend the system by implementing
the corresponding API in the case of the
models this would be equivalent to
implementing three functions that are
explained in the systems documentation
this concludes a brief summary of the
main features of label sleuth intuitive
UI integrated model training
functionality labeling assistance and
customizability
with all of this together labels lose
creates an easy to use system that
enable domain experts to quickly build
text classifiers on their own no AI
knowledge required
for instance to go back to the example
of the IBM lawyers that we started this
presentation with with labels with they
were able to work for about six hours to
build a classifier that saved them about
80 percent of the time that they would
have otherwise needed in order to go
through the context and identify
the Clauses that are risky
if you want to learn more about the
system please visit the website at
label-luth.org where you can find
information on how to install enter
layout the system documentation a link
to our GitHub repository where you can
check out the code and contribute to the
project as well as a slack space where
you can join the discussion about the
system
hope to see you all there thank you
thank you very much
oh
thank you very very much guys uh
you got a couple more minutes would you
like to answer any questions
sure
how do we do this
oh uh please
I'm checking the route
you mentioned how sluice can send uh
suspicious labels back to the expert
does sleuth keep track of how often a
label has been re-evaluated and consider
that when suspiciousness
uh when determining suspiciousness of a
label
thank you thank you for the question so
currently no but I can imagine how easy
it to contribute this piece of uh code
to label sloth and by that generate a
new way to identify suspicious labels
and help fix more types of labeling
errors
and as we've mentioned this is an open
source and we call out for the community
to join and add features
as needed
still do we have any other questions
I may add about support of various
languages so
we build layers list with a English
models but it is very easy to add
additional languages for instance an
external contributor from Italy asked
about Italian we didn't have it after a
few I think hours of work he was able to
upload the stopward list and love
representation for Italian and now
levels support Italian so in terms of
presenting the documents running the
models everything is ready for
multilingual you just need to specify a
couple of files describing the language
the of your interest